bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de robotique on est sur le stand aux crs
de la société hi tech high tech a
développé ont effectivement des robots
qui seront plus destiné au grand public
sur du jeu sur du jouet là on est par
contre seront donnés sur la robotique
grand public un produit d'avenir qui
promet d'être vraiment génial
[Musique]
le robot s'appelle walker qui devrait
être commercialisée elle environ de 2019
on suit vraiment améliorée alors pour
l'instant c'est des jambes
intro est quelque chose qui lui serre
tête ont valu rajouter les bras on va
aller plus vers une fonctionnalité plus
humanoïdes et on pourra faire plein de
choses
[Musique]
quelles sont les différentes
applications qu'on peut avoir avec
walker qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec
au coeur peut marcher cheveux un peu
des descentes de monter ou descendre les
escaliers
d ok
détecter des choses
des attaques de
ce
proche d'accord donc il peut détecter
des obstacles et les contourner contre
on est et on peut contourner comme pour
aller chercher le ballon tout à l'heure
il peut tourner et fait tourner il paie
et chercher les ballons et que
[Musique]
donc il peut suivre et d qui peut
détecter et suivre directement des
objets hockey et quelques actions les
actions spéciales
[Musique]
à toi pour faire danser un peu il faire
faire des pas des choses un peu
particulière oui
effet comique et un son
concrètement walker pour l'instant il
est paraît il n'est pas prêt il est pas
vendu non and the mill
2009les 1019 il sera sur le marché et
qu'est ce qu'est ce qui pourra nous
apporter au quotidien
qu'est ce que les robots comme walker
pour vraiment nous apporter dans un
futur proche et un communiqué
avec nous il peut
faire de ce brouillard est ce qu'il peut
il peut il peut surveiller par exemple
les enfants les importe si vos enfants à
marcher notre
place de sucre d'accord ok ok ce fait
est ce qu elle s qui sera compatible
avec des solutions comme
comme google assistante comme un
raisonner avec ça par exemple
nos entre deux routes et lignes
il s'appelle alex à la maison à l'état
pur
[Musique]
nous pourrons ajouter avec ça dans un
cas pour
pour imaginer qu'on puisse allumer la
lumière et la lumière
et tout ça donc c'est vraiment
un assistant personnalisé à la maison
puis ok bon merci
[Rires]
le manioc 6,9 et goûter mais pour que je
profite
[Musique]
non
est-on
or ce qui est génial avec des produits
comme walker c'est d'imaginer vraiment
d'avoir un robot à la maison comme
quelqu'un qui va surveiller votre maison
alors pour l'instant il n'est pas
connectée encore les solutions comme
alexa com google
aum mais on pourrait très bien imaginer
que ce qu'on était dans les années à
venir et qui peut vraiment apporter des
solutions chez vous faire de la
surveillance
regardez si tout va bien pourquoi pas
arroser les plantes
la porte on peut imaginer énormément de
soldes et ça c'est vraiment l'avenir en
termes de technologie connectés on va
plus loin on va effectivement qu'au delà
des techno connecter sur des enceintes
connectés mais des robots comme walker
sont vraiment les choses qui demain vont
prendre place dans nos maisons et vont
nous aider au quotidien
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez
parce que moi je vous conseille vraiment
intéressant c'est un défi pour nous
c'est peu probablement une évolution
même si on va plus loin pour l'humanité
que des produits comme walker puisse
exister chez nous et nous apporter
davantage de choses dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire ce que ça
c'est vraiment un sujet hyper
intéressant et on en est qu'au début
donc quand ça va évoluer dans les temps
à venir on va voir des robots qui
ressembleront plus ça des humains seront
un peu moins flippant parce que ça
aurait classé on est quand même très
très loin et on n'a pas trop envie de
lui faire la bise mais c'est pas grave
hein c'est pas ça reste qu'un robot donc
mettez moi tout ça en discutant sens
parce que vous allez voir qu'il va y
avoir énormément ce sont les années à
venir
et bien évidemment on va surveiller ça
abonnez vous les religions et pousse et
à très bientôt
[Musique]